Ми спілкуємося з Сандрою у її київській квартирі. І вона налякана.
"Це затримання, з цих сумнівних причин
Я думаю, що жіще станеться?
Щоб його прибрати, вони можуть багато чого зробити,
маючивеликігроші і владу."
Останні кілька років Сандра Рулофс живе між Грузією і Україною.
Зазвичай родина зустрічається на вихідних.
Але останні місяці – виняткові.
Її чоловік став опозиціонером і апатридом,
небажаною особою у обох цих державах.
Сандра зараз не виходить з квартири без охоронців,
які доволі професійно уникають нашої відеокамери.
Найбільше вона боїться не за себе, а за свого чоловіка.
Його можуть в будь-який момент депортувати до Грузії,
де проти нього порушені чотири кримінальні справи.
В день затримання Міхеіла Сандра написала в Фейсбук,
що не може знайти правильні слова,  аби пояснити дітям,
чому їхній батько, якого запросили змінювати Україну на краще,
опинився у в’язниці.
Основним місцем проживання Сандри вже 20 років є Тбілісі,
де мешкає і їхній молодший син Ніколас.
Тут вона пережила найзірковіші часи,
коли була першою леді Грузії.
Про цей час ця книжка «Розповідь ідеалістки».
"Треба вірити, що існує справедливість.
Треба вірити, що можна робити те,  що підказує серце.
І цестосується мене, чоловіка, наших дітей.
Що треба хотіти те, що любиш.
до кінця намагатися змінити щось в цих сферах на позитив".
Сандра – голландка. Окрім рідної мови,
володіє ще німецькою, англійською, російською, грузинською та французькою.
Якби не знайомство з Саакашвілі, вона б, певно, працювала викладачем мов.
Чи відчуває вона себе щасливою людиною як дружина політика-опозиціонера?
"Це дуже добре питання.
Я просто не знаю, як би це було інакше.
Якби я залишилася Нідерландах, була б там одружена,
то, можливо,я б викладала французьку мову.
Це була моя мрія.
Але тоді б моє життя не було сповненим пригод.
Навряд чи я б так багато побачила."
Сандра у шлюбі з Міхеілом – майже 25 років.
Теперішня криза, каже вона, згуртувала їх ще більше.
Життя з Міхеілом, який не може без політики і боротьби,
вона  називає «школою життя»
і готоваскладати іспитиідалі.